oh it was crazy dude he was one of the
clients a really small penis very odd I
got paid though transactions do have a
deal no emotions here no emotions yeah
he came in my mouth high-fived me and it
was it
is this person the [__] yes probably
if they're writing it yet this one's
really really funny anyone who rides it
usually is
so this guy right he he does photo
editing for a living
a client hires him to do an editing job
just two photos ten bucks a piece twenty
dollars is the bill oh wow yeah and the
reason that the client is asking for
this to be done is that the client lied
on a resume for a job and said that she
could edit photos but she can't so she
goes hey can you do this for me and the
guy goes yeah okay cool he finishes the
job
she's ignoring all of the requests from
payment and he's like hey 20 bucks
uh those photos that he completed ended
up already being used on a website so
he's like I can see that you're using it
I need my 20 bucks yeah she's still not
uh addressing the issue 20 I know just
out of principle so he ends up going all
right you want to do that
contacts her employer and says hey I'm
the one that she paid to do the photo
work that you think she's doing
and then she gets mad uh hits him up and
goes you jeopardize my job over 20 bucks
you stole from me yeah yeah and he's
going wait so who's the [__] am I the
[__] oh that's clear as [__] she's
the [__] she's the [__] dude right
but some people also think that goes too
far no no no you don't get to stipulate
what's too far when you've already done
something wrong that's yeah the
consequences happen that way it looks
like I said unless there's no death
happening you get what you [__] get
all right you decided to go ahead and
first of all take advantage of
somebody's [__] kindness right
because they could have done a lot
[__] worse yep take a show to pick
your [__] house and broke your
kneecaps true yeah well it's like you
guys made a deal already and then you
[__] turn your back yeah and the
other side of the payment is like you
know like we have heard stuff like that
when it comes to monetary things and
this is the strangest thing to me too is
when the the mount is small so you on
your end you think that should be no
problem on there and they think that's
not a lot of money it should be no
problem like it's like a scarier done
deal so weird it doesn't the the weird
thing is it's like what the [__] does
your emoji have to do with this business
transaction I don't give a [__] what you
value that twenty dollars to be what you
owe me is what you [__] owe me you
agree to the terms I've told this story
a million times and you're gonna hear it
again I don't give a [__] so I know this
guy
I told you recently but there was a guy
that owed me money that I paid him for a
[__] project right this was when I
first came to La when I first came to La
I had [__] no money I was asked out
right sucking dick on these treats yeah
it was crazy dude he was one of the
clients a really small penis very hot I
got paid though transactions blew up a
deal no emotions here no emotions yeah
he came in my mouth high-fived me and it
was it you guys better business you're a
good Hagler I don't got my 20 bucks but
what if I give you a high five deals you
know
but guy paid him for this like music
project thing and he ghosted me for like
two three weeks and this is a friend of
mine right he's a friend so there's
already two [__] fallacies here but
what business is business this guy plays
guitar or something huh he does blanket
talk but it sounds like a guitar player
he [__] up he does this [__] can we
guess at the end yeah yeah I'll let you
know who he is a little okay [__]
um long story short with this guy
what he's he's a [__] he habitually
likes to find people that he could get a
one-up on and he just ditches them now
this is like my first life lesson in
finding finding out that likable people
aren't good people right and you know
you get fooled a lot by these people
because they're so good at like sweet
talking to you they say the right things
when you talk about a topic they know
everything about that topic they kind of
do this really well no now you get a
little older you get smarter with this
[__] I wasn't very smart I was 24 at the
time so he decides to just ghost me
right but then we have all mutual
friends and I told them about this
stupid [__] that he was doing they're
like hey he's actually at his house
right now he's back from whatever said
City so I just texted him and I was like
listen I know you're at your house now
you imma give you a few hours or
whatever set amount of time to show up
at my place with the project or I'm
gonna [__] you up that's all that it is
right
he comes to my house
he comes to my apartment at the time I
was living out in uh Pasadena comes in
and I just chew him the [__] out on like
like I'm his parent I basically told him
like look this thing was going to make
me money money that I don't have I'm
really paying my [__] bills like are
you out of your [__] mind chew them
out and I was like look if I ever
[__] see you again it's on site you
see me you walk to the other side of the
[__] room right
to him in his mind he's like oh I he
literally told me he goes no I got busy
it doesn't even matter if you got busy
or not what you weren't because I knew
the person that he latched himself onto
and he burned that bridge as well so
business is [__] business even if
we're friends you I paid you for this
you owe me this this is not there's no
emotions to this you owe me this project
this guy had the audacity years later he
married somebody who's very successful
herself I see him at this event where
people who actually do work are allowed
to come in he's there just because he's
married to this person comes up to me
right
that [__] you [__] up he goes what's
up bro how you been so try to hug me
this is what I do what's up bro I was
like what the [__] did I tell you the
last time I said what was I gonna do
dead silent I was like I told you the
next time
foreign
[Laughter]
it's too late like the apology is done
you showed what you literally were
trying to take money from me when I
could barely pay my bills get the [__]
out of my face he goes out his wife had
to come up and apologize she was I told
him not to come up
I'm really close with her she's probably
like he's five no no no you don't know
babe you don't know him like I do yeah
we're good now we're good and funny
thing is I hooked them up together so
she knew like the rules I was like why
do you come up to me because he goes I
don't know like I'm so sorry I told him
not to come up to you I was like good
don't let that happen again I'll [__]
sock him up in this place and I was so
pissed like even now when I talk about I
get so mad because I would never ever do
that to a friend right or even in a
business yeah I could call him a friend
yeah yeah you know what I mean like that
[__] sticks with me for [__] life I
can't believe passion would do something
Jeremy Passion
that's funny thing like Jeremy fashion I
love him because I used to Lemonade such
a good song
it is I grew up listening to this fool
so much he because of him I lost my
virginity because I used to cover his
music all the time and I made that joke
and I told him I actually met him at a
wedding because he was performing at a a
mutual friend's like wedding uh and I
saw him and he was like oh what's up bro
he goes I heard the podcast we said you
must have returned to my music and let
me tell you something I didn't realize
this but because he was such a huge part
of my high school life
to me like meeting him we're not equal
he's here oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know what I mean and I think because
we're similar in Age and what do you
think I've seen your stuff like your
stuff is great I'm like I don't think
you understand I'm a fan you know I mean
so the way I was talking about hey man
so like dude I [__] love your stuff
bro can I get a picture you're going
sure you're not a virgin
let me tell you something man
and I can tell like I'm making him
really uncomfortable right because I
can't stop Fanboy meeting this guy yeah
he's The Godfather in a way yeah he is
he really is Trailblazer for sure he
really started like putting out this
image of like Asian people can sing
outside of what we saw from like William
Hung right I like this
[Laughter]
yeah and you know he started
incorporating a lot of these like jazz
chords into like guitar which you can
see a lot from like a really good
musicianship really right and you could
tell like his biggest influence like
music Soul Child from his like chord
progressions and stuff and he was able
to do it in his own he was like the
first really well done application of
true musical skill yeah I'm from Asians
like all the [__] that Asians could do
but they didn't do it that way it's like
math was good like geometry and then he
put it in there it like awakened
everybody else and went hey I can do
that but why don't I do that it was like
such a strange thing and what I was
telling him too like just out of respect
I wanted to let him know like how much I
appreciated him was that you know no
matter what you do from here or not
you've reached a certain level of
respect that people literally fight
their whole lives for you have Legacy
people don't get to have Legacy right
you might be popular you might make
YouTube videos whatever the [__] you
want but there are certain people who
have made such an impact that their
legacy will live forever people play
your music at weddings still till this
[__] day do you guys remember when
Justin Bieber was make when he was a
YouTuber covering his music yeah yeah
and under influences he said passion and
Usher Yeah
him Gabe bundock uh and Melissa polinar
dude dude and they put out a
collaboration album not too long ago and
I didn't know about that that [__] made
me tear up because of it it just it was
so nice to see these people who made
such a lasting impact on a new
generation of like young Asian musicians
they're still [__] doing it and on
top of that they're not just cover
artists which a lot of like Asian
American musicians were called they're
karaoke artists you know Jason chance
and so what we have
they're karaoke Stars dude Jason I love
you you cover Rockets is the only person
I know that has never missed a YouTube
video a day in his life like I just did
it for money dude
he literally said it on the podcast
now Jason's [__] great dude but um he
has original his original music is
better than his covers and you don't
really get to see that from a lot of
people at that time because everybody
was getting recognized for music that
they would copy versus the stuff that
they would create Melissa polynard's
music dude her as a writer I look up to
her so [__] much man she was on my
podcast she played I was like tearing up
wow and I was like let's make love
passion is not the dude that you were
gonna beat up no no no no no no no no
nobody would do that to Passion okay but
this story just jumped so fast he just
went to pass I'm like where are we at
all right cool it's another Filipino guy
it's a Filipino guy man with a guitar oh
he's amazing you could probably guess Jr
Aquino
incorrect
foreign